[Musique]
vous avez déménagé après un appartement
à paris est ce que ça vous a posé des
problèmes financiers des problèmes
financiers n'ont pas tellement mais j'ai
quand même ici des problèmes financiers
samantha poser bon parce que j'ai habité
tout seul donc
donc il faut se rémunérer et j'ai quand
même tenu à travailler plus par
expérience que que pour l'argent
lui-même et donc je travaille le samedi
soir je suis un réceptionniste de nuit
dans un hôtel le samedi soir j'ai bossé
un chèque de vis de moi de me dire ont
gelé ces je les prends deux temps par
semaine porte elle reste la caisse d'epa
apprendre tant par semaine je pose mon
argent comme cela en liquide sur mon
bureau
et puis où quelque part chez moi puis je
puisse du temps comme un malade au début
et puis mais c'est régulier ça au bout
de 15 jours
j'avais fait un rang silva vous n'avez
pas encore 18 ans vous avez péché vos
parents et vous êtes heureux d'y être
apparemment voilà on est pour qu'il
n'avait pas de projet de départ n'ont
pas pour l'instant il ne nous manque
rien chez vous comment me manquerez plus
si j'étais battu moi qu'il manquerait
améliorée
plein de petits problèmes en plus très
bien de leur vaisselle 20 points je
parle honte à le dire c'est vrai que ça
j'ai comme je fais rien je vois pas de
danse jour là je brûle l'ambiance
familiale ne vous a jamais manqué normes
ster que mes parents quand ceux ci quand
je suis un peu comme je me dis que les
parents aient existé pour moi c'est
sécurisé on a ça ça me rassure c'est
peut-être un petit peu facile de se dire
ne pas les supporter en tant que même
c'est à dire de palliser avec eux mais
de me dire qu'ils sont là et qu'en cas
de coup dur même ça tu remets pas invite
à 350 km/h et qu'en cas de coup dur ils
sont là ils tous c'est dit j'ai passé un
mois chez mes parents je pouvais face et
parler c'est un support je sais pas moi
de dont on ma mère m'appelait pour venir
at alors que je dois rend compte que je
suis confus voire à partir du moment où
vous avez une bac en fait vous avez pu
partir de chez vous facilement
oui parce que c'est le box c'est la
condition pour que je puisse m'établir
après et comment ça s'est passé
progressivement comment vous avez
expliqué samantha recette est très
progressif disons que la dernière j'ai
réussi à faire prendre conscience à mes
parents que la banlieue c'était loin les
transports c'était fin qui avait rien à
faire d'un bail on admet que de façon si
je voulais sortir les gens reviennent à
paris alors sont eux qui finalement
compris et que j'aille à paris
maintenant il ya aussi le fait qu'à 20
ans n'a envie d'être tout seul de
recevoir nos amis quand on veut de vivre
enfin suivant un mode de vie qui nous
est propre
vous êtes ici depuis ma d'octobre alors
comment vivez-vous entre vos quatre murs
j'ai pas eu d une période ivresse est à
dire que j'ai je suis devenu tout fou
dans cet appartement puis petit à petit
j'ai pris un ride
ça va très très bien enfin c'est un peu
la vie que je menais chez moi mais les
contraintes à moins que je mange à
l'heure où je veux je fais ce que je
veux je reçois qui joue beaucoup d'amis
est-ce que les problèmes matériels on
vous ont beaucoup ennuyé je dire la
vaisselle les choses comme ça le ménage
mais au début ça m'a amusé mais est très
vite devenu une corvée
vous allez au restaurant universitaire
non comment faites vous je veux préparer
cuisine je l'aide matérielle mans oui
petits travaux ménagers qui négligent
pas ce que ne sait pas le faire ou parce
qu'il n'a pas l'habitude on vous
continuer un peu votre rôle m'a jamais
allé le voir parce que j'aime bien le
relais avec lui puis se confient
volontiers votre soeur et l'emmener où
par rapport à vous quand même désir
d'indépendance
disons que chaque fois qu'il ya des
heurts avec les parents leur envie de
partir puis sinon résultant est bien
chez elle avait un frère qui vient de
prendre un appartement ça veut dire est
vivre avec nous mais tout en ayant des
rapports avec ma famille et de bons
rapports
enfin c'est très agréable de jouer avec
son frère et entre le garçon et la fille
est ce que vous avez fait des
différences
non pas vraiment est ce que vous trouvez
que les filles sont au moins de liberté
que les garçons à non je trouve qu'elles
sont beaucoup moins de liberté enfin
pour moi parce que je m'offre ma mère
comment elle a élevé mon frère comment
elle m'a élevé
facilité que moi est sorti bien sûr il
est plus cher il a cinq ans plus que moi
mais je n'ai pas les mêmes libertés que
mon frère ce que je permets hanafi même
si c'est peu de chose je n'avais pas le
droit de le faire moi-même francs que
vous habitez paris non j'habite arpajon
et je reviens tous les soirs chez moi
pour l'instant je suis bien chez moi
j'aime bien l'ambiance familiale le fait
de me retrouver seul des fois des
semaines
quand j'ai un peu le cafard oui bon ça
me dira rien pour l'instant ça me vient
et quand vous allez chez doivent par
exemple qui lui habite seul à trouver
que c'est pas mal je n'ai pas envie de
vivre la même chose qu'une chine mais
pas pour l'instant non les départs ne
sont pas tous vécu dans la confiance
parents et enfants se déchirent parfois
en chantage sentimentaux et matériels
mais ceux que nous avons rencontrés
n'ont pas voulu témoigner
quelquefois aussi c'est malgré eux que
les jeunes s'éloignent du foyer de leur
enfance didier vous avez 19 ans si vous
n'habitez plus chez vos parents depuis
combien de temps
depuis trois ans donc vous êtes 10
mineurs quand vous êtes parti quand je
suis porté sur le second vous êtes parti
pour pas faire pour faire un
apprentissage je cuisine qui a duré
combien de temps deux ans et ça c'était
avec l'accord de vos parents
ponctuellement si ça leur plaisait pas
avec le chat ce métier là il voulait un
autre chose de simple s de pommes donc
vos rapports n'étaient pas très bons non
c'est pour ça que je suis parti alliance
vous êtes martinique et vous êtes à
paris depuis longtemps et depuis deux
ans ça va faire bientôt deux ans que je
suis à paris et pourquoi être venu à
paris ils ont depuis au lycée j'avais
une folle envie de venir à paris tout le
monde parlait de paris alors ça m'a
donné nous dit pardon c'est pourquoi
j'ai décidé de venir
vos parents étaient d'accord et pas du
tout parce que quand je suis quand j'ai
décidé de partir n'est pas on n'était
pas au courant du tout alors qu'est ce
que vous avez fait puis il fallait bien
qu'un jour que je leur dise que je vais
m'en aller puis est justement comment ça
s'est passé ce jour là
ce jour là c'est 10 en une semaine avant
le départ ils étaient tous à table alors
je les ai dit que j'ai déjà mon billet
que comme j'avais une soeur qui était
habité la région parisienne alors ça
m'intéressait de partir alors je leur ai
dit que je partais pas et vous trouver
l'argent pour payer ce pilier vision
j'avais dix économies de côté et puis
j'avais déjà que j'ai eus immobilier
quoi
non vous êtes depuis un an à paris dans
un foyer
non pourquoi avez vous choisi ce mode de
logement ah ben c'est quand je suis
arrivé j'étais à luton l'hôtel était
cher aussi
c'était impossible de trouver un studio
j'avais des finances qui suivent pas
alors je me suis retrouvé ici c'est
quand même moins cher ils ont barriquand
ton arrivée qu'on connaît personne on se
fait des amis et vous êtes toujours
fasciné par paris et non là c'est fini
là pour moi parler ça ça n'existe plus
qu on à paris alors pourquoi vous êtes
revenu en france vivre seul suis venu en
france parce que la partie de la france
on peut connaître pas mal de pays
d'europe
ça m'intéressait beaucoup parce que moi
comme je fais de la musique au niveau de
la musique c'est déjà pas mal pour moi
quoi vous êtes aussi martiniquaise jette
en france depuis combien de temps ça
fait un an
exact l'âge 18 ans donc vous êtes venu à
17 ans avec l'accord de vos parents ah
non comment avez vous fait g j'étais en
martinique
et puis j'étais chez ma tante et comme
je m'entendais pas très bien avec ma
tante puis la chance surtout en guyane
et là j'ai donné j'étais devant ma grand
mère puis là elle a payé mon billet pour
moi je suis venu à paris et pourquoi
partir si loin
pourquoi pas résister en martinique ah
non moi je peux pas rester en martinique
parce que en martinique déjà y en a pas
de boulot pour les femmes et 300 martin
il faudra aussi faire le ménage chez soi
et ça vous parle pas mais je m'entendais
pas du tout avec mon père je suis parti
chercher du travail à paris vous avez
arrêté vos études j'ai travaillé j'ai
arrêté mes études ma terminale et je
suis à paris
qu'est ce qui leur plaisait pas c'était
que vous arriviez arrêté les études que
vous partiez que j'aille à paris c'est
paris qui voulait pas que c'est un lieu
de dépravation ce que vous voulez
veulent pas entendre parler partout
bien moi j'ai arrêté l'école où les
rares une semaine et je commençais un
colis 6 thomas janvier qui en attendant
on va je dessine je fais du shopping
globale at il ajouté
j'ai eu mon bac l'année dernière et la
cherche un peu de boulot à un mi-temps
et puis mon cas vous prendrez en montage
de films aussi illustratrice et ben moi
j'ai arrêté mes études de droit et
j'essaye de de me brancher cinéma aux
journalistes
donc la reine m'a dit tu me permets si
je travaille de partir mais je veux pas
partir donc j'ai pas de situation stable
enfin un travail parce que je veux pas
me serrer la ceinture
je veux pas non mais c'est vrai je veux
pas me priver je préfère passer dans de
bonnes conditions dans un appartement
déjà enfin je pense à ranger
l'appartement avant d'y habiter
non mais c'est important de s'installer
papa les travaux chez soi
le côté pique nique dans l'appartement
j'aime j'aime bien le petit
[Musique]
c'est pas les études qui a qui ont fait
que j'ai rompu avec mes parents c'est
plutôt
le fait que j'acceptais plus ce rapport
parent enfant par l'intermédiaire de par
le biais de l'argent de lait des études
de la famille de toutes les obligations
que vous connu c'est pas parce que j'ai
des problèmes avec mes parents je suis
libre tu peux sortir quand je veux je
vais très souvent dîner chez des amis
et j'invite moins de gens parce que
j'aime pas la présence de ma mère quand
j'ai des congés des amis on m'a
tellement parce que je sais pas si on
peut pas rigoler comme on est toujours
une certaine tenue à voir en face des
parents les parents y ont fait où
l'europe est poli ou officielle veut
faire quelque chose s'est elle impose
son truc à elle si elle veut regarder la
télévision je peux vous dire normal on
est un attaquant mais de la musique
qu'est ce que ça va vous apporter de
vivre seul m'importe c'est que ça va
m'apporter la liberté la liberté haute
dire si je veux rester toute une journée
dans mon lit a traîné à lire n'importe
quoi ou à dormir je pourrais le faire
et puis j'aurais moins d'obligations
parce que pas de chez moi le repas de
midi le dimanche c'est la tradition ma
mère fait le bon plat bien mijoté vous
et puis elle aime bien qu'on soit
présentable la table contre prends 200
quand on mange donc
il ya la contrainte qui ont fait on peut
pas manger à 4 de l'après-midi bon ben
on a une heure c'est important les
horaires d'avoir ces horaires haoues
crois moi j'ai toujours été très très
famille et j'ai donc dû complètement me
rééduquer aura souvent dans les boîtes
pour chambrer en temps seront effacés
on peut pas dire que c'est tentant
d'aller d'aller vivre à l'extérieur
puisque bon le travail mené
1 les choses qu'on compte qu'on a envie
de faire on peut pas souvent les
réaliser le voyage ou n'est plus
tellement envisageable
pour ma part je reste quand même très
matérialiste et donc j'ai j'ai envie
d'un h et moyens d'une tranquillité
[Musique]